letzte woche hat sich unser aller leben
für immer verändert und ich behaupte sie
haben es überhaupt nicht gemerkt am 6
november hat die bundesregierung
beschlossen ab 2020 sind in deutschland
plastiktüten verboten gigantischer
erfolg für umwelt ministerin schulze
du sollst nicht töten ab sofort das
elfte gebot im extra novellierten
verpackungsgeschäft genau deswegen wurde
die svenja bei ihrer pk zum thema auch
übels ab gefeiert also von den
journalisten die sich viel plastik
interessieren
so jetzt die schlechte nachricht leider
machen die plastiktüten nur ein prozent
ein einziges prozent unseres
plastikmülls in deutschland aus nicht
verboten werden zum beispiel diese
kleinen händchen beutel wissen sie für
obst und gemüse obwohl man dafür einen
eigenen einkaufsbeutel beutel mit
bringen könnte trotz neuem verpackungs
gesetz bleibt deutschland europameister
beim plastikmüll
das feiert man nicht der anteil der
anteil von mehrweg getränkeflaschen ist
bei uns zuletzt sogar gesunken
gesunken warum gibt es keine bußgelder
für übermäßig verpackte produkte und
wann werden endlich diese bescheuerten
blisterverpackungen verboten kennen sie
die die aus ganz hart und kunststoff die
man nie aus kriegt das ist wirklich für
mich der ultimative veit mensch gegen
blister ein totales massaker und für uns
als menschen praktisch nicht zu gewinnen
niemand weiß wie viele menschen jedes
jahr auf der strecke bleiben bei diesem
völlig aussichtslosen kampf nur eins ist
klar
noch nie hat jemand eins dieser scheiß
teile auf gekriegt noch nie
[Musik]
ja es ist uns allen schon passiert meine
damen und herren minister verpackung
ich gut gemeint mit den tieren aber es
ist nur ein prozent unsere offizielle
deutsche recycling quote liegt zwar bei
fast 50 prozent aber tatsächlich
recycelt also zu neuen verpackungen
gemacht werden gerade mal 16 prozent
weil wir und das ist wirklich ein cooler
trick ins ausland exportierten und bei
uns verbrannten müll als recycle zählen
und das was da herauskommt das ist das
entscheidet dass das plastik was wir
verwenden das dass am ende wieder
eingesetzt wird ja aber das konnte ich
möchte das mit dem verbrannten vision
dass nach beamte plastik fließt das
helferteam quote mit einem recycling wo
ich weiß es nicht da bin ich ja ach muss
jedoch nicht wissen als umweltministerin
ja immer ein alarmsignal wenn der typ
von rtl besser bescheid weiß als du
faustregel neues plastik herstellen ist
bei uns viel billiger als altes recycle
warum weil die herstellung von plastik
mit 1,5 milliarden pro jahr
subventioniert wird also mit staatsknete
warum da sind wir doch selber schuld an
der plastik flut dachte ich jedenfalls
bis mir dieser afd man hier die augen
geöffnet hat
dass sich die plastik vermüllung der
meere überhaupt zu einem großen problem
entwickelt hat liegt vornehmlich an
afrikanischen und asiatischen staaten
die weltweit zu den größten verursachern
gehören ja danke afd playmobilmännchen
für diese belehrung ja
man hätte es sich denken können schuld
ist also wie immer der junge
alleinreisende müll aus afrika wie
zynisch kann man sein deutschland wir
exportieren unseren müll in
entwicklungsländer und geben denen dann
die schuld wenn das zeug im meer landet
malaysia zum beispiel oder wie ist ein
reiseführer neuerdings heißt müll leise
ja offiziell erlaubt sind müll exporte
zwar nur in länder die recycelt aber die
realität sieht leider anders aus hier
das ist ein dorf in malaysia wohl
gemerkt dass es keine müllkippe das ist
das dorf da liegt auch ohne ende unser
gar um ritter sport spa keks hier mein
lieblingslied von den flippers die gelbe
tonne von barbados gilt seit mai das
sogenannte basler übereinkommen das 187
staaten verpflichtet plastik nur noch
sortenrein also voll recycelbar zu
exportieren kontrollieren soll das
sollen das zum einen unsere bundesländer
zum anderen ist wenn sie in den
internationalen bereich geht natürlich
auch der zoll hier eine entscheidende
behörde
der deutsche zoll verweist bei unserer
anfrage nach einer kontrolle auf die
fachbehörden der bundesländer bei den
behörden verweist man zurück an den zoll
ich hab da ein gutes gefühl meine damen
und herren
da frage ich lieber auf sicher noch mal
nach was ich noch nicht ganz kapiert hat
wer ist jetzt zuständig ich weiß es
nicht
macht nichts macht nix kurz gesagt unser
neues verpackungs gesetz rettet den
planeten wohl leider nicht immerhin
müssen wir sagen immerhin gibt es
einzelne deutsche branchen die sich
schon mühe geben in sachen recycling
meine eigene zum beispiel für uns von
der deutschen humor industrie ist
klimaschutz eben nicht nur ein wort
natürlich fahre ich jeden morgen
klimaneutral zur arbeit
100 erneuerbarer energie wir sind stolz
dass unsere heute show zu über 40
prozent aus recycelten alten witzen
besteht
viele sind bauen sondern die wegschmeißt
häschen in einer zoohandlung fragt hat
okada ja wo du nicht so viel saufen der
humor standort deutschland ist ein
geschlossener kreislauf
denn wenn ich nach feierabend das
drehbuch mit den alten witzen des tages
wegschmeißen weiß ich genau irgendeinen
comedian wird diese text nochmal
verwertet
[Musik]
mutter nicht so viel saufen
deutsche witze sie werden einfach nie
schlecht
[Applaus]
geht doch wenn man will
ich habe es eben schon gesagt manche
branchen geben sich halt mühe andere tun
nur so als würden sich mühe geben
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von vorsicht falle
nepper schlepper müll verkäufer
[Applaus]
wirklich hauer
deutschlands verbraucher zentralen
warnen vor einer besonders dreisten
masche greenwashing immer mehr firmen
bieten angeblich nachhaltige produkte an
die gar nicht nachhaltig sind
moment mal sie wollen wir jetzt nicht
erzählen ich hätte die drei kästen
krombacher jeden tag gar nicht für den
regenwald getrunken
aktuelles beispiel wer eine flasche fado
spiel der firma henkel kauft dem wird
suggeriert diese flasche sei aus ocean
plastik also müll aus dem ozean
dabei wird er irgendwo an land gesammelt
und auch henkel relativiert auch der
flasche stehe gar nicht dass sie außen
plastik sei sondern nur das ocean
plastik bekämpft werde
stattdessen handele es sich um social
plastic ja aus social plastik bestehen
übrigens große teile der gesichter der
geist ja andere geschichte auch die
firma adidas verkauft schuhe mit ocean
plastik das gar nicht aus dem ocean ist
adidas sagt unsere konsumenten
verhindern durch den kauf dass
plastikmüll in die ozeane gelangt exakt
wenn sie zu hause nicht sofort adidas
schuhe bestellt
dann müssen sie auch ihrer kleinen
tochter erklären warum nemo und dori
jämmerlich in einem sixpack alter
verrecken fun fact adidas verkauft jedes
jahr 400 millionen paar schnur die
natürlich nicht recycelt werden oder
nespresso gehört zum nestlé-konzern und
scheiß den planeten zu mit george
clooneys blöden kaffeekapseln die werben
jetzt damit dass aus diesen kapsel neue
hipster bikes entstehen gerade mal 300
kapseln pro fahrradrahmen jetzt der
wird's nur in deutschland verursachten
espresso 8000 tonnen atommüll
jedes jahr muss eine alte frau lange für
fahrräder schweiz aber bitte ist nicht
schön aber wie soll man ohne kapseln
kaffeekochen es ist ja bis heute noch
keine andere methode erfunden worden
liebe zuschauer
greenwashing ist brainwash -ing
achten sie mal darauf wie viele produkte
uns mit selbstverständlichkeiten
täuschen es werden immer noch spraydosen
verkauft mit dem slogan fckw frei dabei
ist der stoff seit 1991 sowieso verboten
das ist so als ob ich ein glas babybrei
habe worauf ich schreibe jetzt ganz ohne
hunde gut
andere kleben auf ihre produkte
irgendwelche bilder von blumen oder
wolken
das wirkt wie ein offizielles siegel ist
es aber gar nicht hier beispiel eine
packung fertig buletten von der tanke
ärzte sagen drei davon können ein
ausgewachsenes pferd töten aber vorne
ist ein siegel mit einem grünen einhorn
drauf und jetzt denken sehr dumme kunden
natürlich
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort